anyone have a weird story of how they
met yeah what do you got
ooh spicy
yep right yep so you independently go
then your significant others meet each
other at the concert well how we were
uh
her boyfriend
if he could move so that my girlfriend
can get a better View and then he was
like yeah sure yeah sure should I
her
[Applause]
yeah you want me to move so she has a
better view what if I just her and
take her away from you is that a good
plan too
how about this I'll do you one better
I'm gonna start dating her and uh yeah
is that good for you yeah yeah no
problem no she deserves a better View
and a better relationship she deserves a
lot of better I'm gonna give it all
to her
[Applause]
man